okay welcome everyone welcome to the
very first NDC Minnesota the first
session after the keynote so hope
everyone's awake and ovarian to go so my
name is stephen haunts and we're talking
today about protecting encryption keys
using Azure key volt so it's not just
about the default use of key volt in
Azure it's about how we can actually
program against the key volt so I'm a
freelance developer and independent
trainer for run a business called Steven
hunch training I've also been writing
courses for probably site for the last
four years so now I've got thirteen
courses in the library and I've got
another one on the way soon so before
close I'll subscriber please do watch
more courses and I'm also a consultant
with a company called block free so we
go into companies and we help them
identify whether they actually want a
block chain in their business or what
they now actually understand what it is
they're talking about when it comes to
block chains so we help them work
through that problem a couple of courses
I've got that might be of use to you if
this is a subject to interested in so
the first one is called enterprise data
encryption with Azure reveal so it kind
of covers some and stuff that we can
talk about today but we go a lot more
detail today and I've also got a course
called practical cryptography and net
which goes into quite a lot of depth
about a lot of the crypto API is in
the.net framework and dotnet core so a
brief agenda of what we're going to look
at today so we can talk a little bit
about data breaches and the effects on
companies we're going to do a very quick
critical cryptography overview just make
sure it falls on the same page then
we're gonna explore some of the
different key management options are out
there good and bad and we can introduce
your key role to now I'm going to talk
through various different packs and
patterns and practices that you can use
with the key vault and visual studio so
the fret of data breaches so I always
like to bring this slide up and Adi
talks about security and this is a
website called breach level index comm
and I like to show actually really put
some numbers up there sort of in the
forefront so we can see at the top here
that since 2013 has been nine point
seven billion records slotted or stolen
by companies and a scary thing is that
number doesn't actually really surprise
me anymore it's a problem that's
constantly getting worse the bit that is
worrying is the line underneath where it
says only 4% of breaches were classed to
secure breaches
but by secure they mean you know what's
the dates were encrypted it was being
stolen and only only 4% of cases was
that data actually useless to the people
that stole them Sophie much that's
underneath so about five million records
every day of stolen which is about two
hundred thousand every hour she's three
and a half thousand every minutes or
fifty-eight records every second just
really kind of sort of highlights but
what the problem is or how big the
problem is and we've got some examples
here from the same website so lots of
household names on there especially new
way so JPMorgan Chase had 83 million
records Solem which was a identity theft
Equifax nearly a hundred and fifty
million records stolen MySpace and
surprise have still got three hundred
and sixty million customers but they go
I'm mostly too old for websites like
that and then if you look at websites
like Troy hunt surviving ponies anyone
signed up to this service Detroit house
it's very good so if you sign up to it
whenever your email address appears on a
data breach you get notified so you know
to change your password on that site or
close your account and there's some good
stats on here as well so
Adobe 152 million records LinkedIn 164
million there's a few dodgy websites on
there we won't go through those but it
you know it can happen to any website so
what the effects of data breaches so for
a company you know the organizations
that you work for a data breach could be
quite catastrophic so it can cause a lot
of reputational damage people just won't
trust you anymore that can in turn lead
to a loss of sales so it affects
directly affects your bottom line in
your revenues it could also mean that
customers again won't trust you so I'll
switch to a competitor and once they've
switched they're probably not likely to
come back you can also get lots of legal
action from your customers and other
companies or class-action lawsuits
against you can be very costly and also
this compliance costs I fits a PCI DSS
breach where you've lost card data that
can be quite catastrophic for your
company or other things like HIPPA
health insurance their personal
information and health record to be
install them and it could also
compromise the safety of your customers
depending on what the business is so the
consequences for your company are quite
bad and then also look at the
consequences for the individual so
you've had your personal data lost you
know your name address phone number
email address no that means your address
where you live could be out there on the
internet and you want to look at that
can result in ID theft and impersonation
which can then mean you lose financial
data or people use your financial data
it's been stolen to make purchases
against your account and I could also
mean you've had your transaction history
stolen so if you've bought anything that
you might be you know a bit embarrassing
then that data could be stolen and
people could know about it so it can be
quite a bad effect for the individual as
well but the scary thing is data
breaches these days are inevitable
they're going to happen to any of
everyone or anyone at any point doesn't
matter whether you're a large
multinational conglomerate or whether
you're a small to mid enterprise or even
a small start-up it can literally happen
to anyone so what you need to do is
change your mindset it's not a case of
if you can get beta breached in terms of
your mindset of when you get data breach
and that kind of changes your whole
perception of how you're going to deal
with a problem
they just tend to focus on their
perimeter security settings our
firewalls and intrusion protection
systems and no these are absolutely good
things to do you shouldn't stop doing
that it's not the only thing you should
focus on so what we want to talk about
is encryption so that's encryption of
data at rest and also in transit now you
need to you know spend a lot of time
identifying what it is you want to
encrypt so generally that's going to be
things like personal identifiable
information
anything that can relate back to a
person either living or dead credit card
data no payment card information PCI DSS
regulated data or does anything that's
sensitive to your business you don't be
able to read what the GDP are slidy
papers even over in the u.s. I mean GDP
are what it's European regulation does
very much affect pretty much anyone on
the panik's we live in a digital we
internet economy these days so if your
company has any European customers with
the individuals or companies then GDP
are is very important and this includes
things like how you protect people's
data using encryption you know if they
want their data updated or deleted then
that's their right to do so so you have
to be able to be able to build all these
processes into your systems and the
penalties for a GDP are can be quite
significant so they're designed to hurt
so if you get caught or get caught up by
the regulation okay so let's do a very
quick high-level cryptography overview
of just some of the things that are
going to be playing around with in a bit
so cryptography you can basically be
split down into four core areas or four
pillars so we have confidentiality
this is what everyone typically thinks
on with encryption you have some data
you encrypt it make it secret then
decrypt it integrity this is what we
commonly sold with hashing so you have
some data you quite hashcode of it send
that data across the network
recalculate the hash code for that date
so if they match you know that the date
has come across intact
if the hash codes don't match you know
there's a problem with the integrity of
the data authentication it's kind of an
extension to hashing but it allows you
to do hashing with a encryption key and
what that means is that for someone else
on the receiving end of that beta for
then to calculate the same hash they
have to be in receipt of the same
encryption key if you haven't got the
key then you can't
calculate the hash that's 1/4
authentications is billick palatable
we've got non-repudiation and this
covers things i digital signatures and
what that's effectively you like it's
comes more like a contract so if you
create a digital signature of something
and you can improve that that signature
was created at the appropriate time so
it means come up with a contract if you
sign a contract you can't then go and
deny it later on that's kind of what a
digital signature gives you
I mean dotnet we typically use things
like IES and RSA for encryption and
we've got lots different hashing
algorithms we can use but no very
commonly will use char 256 the Pens
ocation we use something called a hash
message authentication code which is
about to be back in sha-256 hash book
wiki and then we can use digital
signatures then if we use all of those
things together to create different
protocol that's called hybrid encryption
and we can look at some examples of that
little bit later ok so encryption
generally we had two types of symmetric
encryption and asymmetric encryption so
symmetric encryption is where you use
the same key to encrypt and decrypt your
data and typically we will use you know
AES des or reason I could include theirs
and Triple DES on theirs you know you
wouldn't want to use it for a new system
but if you're integrating with an older
legacy system and being able to decrypt
stairs data might be very important to
you
then on the other side of that we have
asymmetric encryption so things like RSA
and the difference air is the key is
split into two they're mathematically
linked keys but you generally what you
encrypt with the public key any decrypt
with the private key so if I want to
send some betas one of you or use your
public key to encrypt the data then you
decrypt it using only your private key
which only you know Arisa Ettrick
encryption it's generally very fast it's
very algorithmic that's what computers
are good at it take today to splits it
down into blocks and does lots of
algorithmic operations to it so it's
very fast but a symmetric key is very
hard to share so if I've got a keen I
encrypt and data how do I give it to one
of you do I send it to you across a
network in the clear that's not a good
idea it'd be intercepted
so need that one or email it to you so
really Denny way of getting the key to
is if I sort of physically earned a - in
person
flip side what things like RSA which
Germany is quite a slow operation is
very mathematical it wheezes prime
numbers and modulus arithmetic perform
its operation so it's not very fast but
what it does give us is a better way of
doing key sharing because the private
key you keeps yourself that's only
your's the public key you can give to
anyone it actually makes the way of
showing key to that lot easier parent
net there's two classes we'll use for
this we use AES crypto service provider
for AES or RSA we use RSA crypto service
provider so sort of a very high-level
overview of some of the crypto
primitives available to us so what about
key management options so we said that
you know Germany keys can be quite
difficult to share so one way you can do
it and I don't recommend doing it but
you know I've worked at simple companies
that have done this I've sort of changed
it when I got there but storing keys in
XML files on a server really bad don't
do it as I sell work for two very large
companies that did do that but you know
it's on a file or a folder in a server
someone can easily access it and take
the piece so don't do that but one we're
already familiar with it is certificate
it got things like Cobra certificates
next 5:09 certificates very robust being
used for a long time everyone
understands and so that's kind of a
really good way of sharing kits and
installing keys on different systems and
they'll store things like a new identity
for your issues to get to and who it's
being issued from specially the public
key verification you can easily install
it on servers and it's a robust
improvement mechanism as a second there
generally it's very well understood some
of the benefits is you know for the
end-user there's minimal involvement if
you're installing a big enterprise
system generally the certificates
automatically installed by the system so
the end user doesn't have to deal with
it you don't need any additional
hardware
you know most modern operating systems
like Windows excetera have a key store
built into the system easy to manage
you know IT systems IT departments all
over the world are used to dealing with
certificates and they're supported by
just about everything but as an actual
level we can go to and that's to use
something called a hardware security
module
so what this is it's a one or two year
background appliance that you put into
your data center got some examples hit
here but there's a few issues with it
women
that's just level eighty-five so first
of all they're tamper proof so if anyone
tries to hack into it it will detect
that and wipe itself and cable the keys
off the system if someone tries to
physically break into the system you
know translate the cover off it will
have lots of tamper mechanisms on that
it will detect when the screws have been
undone and your wipe itself they can
have light sensors temperature sensors
all of the chips are covered in an epoxy
resin onto the board so it's very
difficult to actually read anything from
the chips inside it you can use them for
storing keys and also certificates but
the problem is traditionally odd rescue
team are jewels have been cost
prohibitive for lots of companies I've
worked some sort large banks in the UK
and we did have hsn's in place and also
work for a retail finance company where
we got some hsn's in you had to buy two
of them because our dealer you want one
different data centers with the key
synchronize between the two you know
we'd be paid probably about 75,000
pounds which is what second dollars
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
maybe they're about so they've been very
expensive so for smaller companies it's
kind of saying that you can't really
entertain cuz it's just too expensive
this is where we have wonderful things
like Asia which allows us to do lots of
great things in a cost in a
cost-effective way
so they provide something called a
jockey bolt so a Shiki volt is a wrapper
around physical hardware that stores in
their data centers and it made it very
easy to program against and the hardware
they build it upon is this device it's
called the thallus and shield so they I
don't have neither have babies probably
lots per data center in each of the
regions around the world so they provide
an abstraction over this system which
you can use so they so Microsoft has
taken the hit on the cost of buying
these and devices and we can use them
for very little money and some of the
techniques I'm going to show you later
you've got to get your cost down to
virtually nothing now a jockey
has two concepts you can use hardware in
the software to store keys and do
encryption operations and there's
different pricing tiers which we'll look
at but effectively whether you use the
hardware or the software version all of
your keys are ultimately stored inside
the HSM in Hardware if you use a
software system which is slightly
cheaper than the encryption and
decryption operations are performed on
compute the MS in Asia but using the
keys inside the hard way so because
they're reducing the amount of time than
using the HSM the costs come down a lot
more you can also use the full hardware
version which means all the encryption
and decryption operations actually
happen on the hardware itself you pay a
little bit more for that privilege that
this is a that's kind of the more robust
version of using it so generally the
recommendation is if you're using test
and dev environment emergencies a
software version the results are the
same what you get back and put in but in
your production system you'll want to go
for the full hardware version because
I'll give you the most protection
so if ever quick look at some of the
costs so there's two pricing tier
standard and premium you can use your
key bolts and if you're storing and
things like secrets and we'll talk a bit
more about secrets later but if you're
doing secret operations then it costs
about three cents per 10,000 operations
across both price and tears if you're
doing certificates or storing
certificates and it costs $4.00 per
annual and then 3 cents per 10,000
operations it's already the costs are
quite low so if you're using software
encryption operations so if you're using
the default which is Rs a 2048-bit Keys
and again across both pricing tiers it
costs about 3 cents per 10,000
operations most prices are accurate
about last week and they are introducing
high extremity encryption keys so 3072
and 4096 bit keys currently they're free
because it's in like a preview period I
don't know what the final cost of that
will be but you have the option to use
the higher strength keys if using the
hardware mhsn key operations and the
costs are a little bit higher which is
why I recommend you might want to use a
production and the software ones for
your test environments so these are only
premiums here so RSA 2048 bit keys
you're looking at about $1 per key and
then 3 cents per 10,000 operations and
in the highest roam Keys it's kind of a
tiered pricing model so your first 250
keys will cost you $5 per key and then
that sort scales downwards and then it's
about 15 cents per 10,000 operations a
bit more cost now keeping to a member of
them set like magic Evo words once you
generate a key and it goes in the key
volt it'll never come out again so you
can never see the key and you can
actually do a backup of your keys but
all those keys are encrypted by a master
key on the keyboard so even though you
might back them up in your company can't
actually access the keys inside them
okay so
the key volt and I'm not gonna run
through the process of setting it up you
haven't got time this morning but the
Microsoft documentation is actually
really good and so you just type a Jacke
volt set up or some of that into Google
you'll find it or there's a URL down
there and that will take you through the
process of setting it up
but generally what you do and you set up
these in PowerShell
and create the results group or you
might use an existing resolves group you
create the key volts specifying the
results group the region normal if you
want hardware or software variant and
once you've done that you've got the
ability to create keys read and write
secrets upload certificate and once
that's done you can just access it as a
standard blade in the user interface now
if you want to do programmatic access
against the keyboard which is something
we're going to look at in a moment then
you need to do an extra steps you need
to register your application with Azure
ad all the instructions for doing that
in that website and that gives you your
app ID and shared safest if you need to
use to access the evil
about secret so there's a difference
between the two so keys are RSA
encryption keys so your public and
private key which gets stored in the key
bolts what the secret is is effectively
it's up to 25k of text that you can
store in the keyboard now you don't
control what keys generally used weak as
you can specify the key but what it's
doing is its encrypting text files or
data inside the key bolt which you can
retrieve later so a good excuse well a
good reason fusing it is things like
connection strings or API keys to fair
party systems instead of put them in
config files which you might
traditionally do you can store them as
secret in the key vault so I've got some
sample code which we can now sort of
look through today it's all on github
I've released under an MIT license so
feel free to steal it and do what you
want with it
and each sample application is a console
app that runs completely independently
from the other apps so you can get them
up and running really easily so we're
gonna thankfully some of those today and
hope the Wi-Fi god sir favourable to
this so when he sets up a project and
you have to include a new get package so
it's a Microsoft Azure ducky volt
package and it's dotnet core doc that
standard compliant so I mean I'm doing
it on a Mac it doesn't think it matter
if you're doing it on a Mac or on
Windows and and all these code will work
on normal doc make framework as well you
need to change the project file type so
let's go and have a look at a small
example
so in the solution I've got loads of all
it's a two in the solution I've got
various little projects that you can
play around me which are going to and
cover some of the patterns we're looking
out later so but the first one though
we're going to do a simple encrypt and
decrypt operation on the keyboard so
let's run this and we'll step through it
you
so in the code I've created a I've got a
class here called Kibo I've got some
example client ID and secrets in there
the key vault that uses this is going to
get destroyed after the conference so
you can just go and use this one but
I've got a wrap around some of the stuff
that's in the client library from
Microsoft so I'm only exposing the
detrol bits that we need
so what we're going to do is we're going
to step through this and to create the
key vault so now we've been saturated
the key vault is maintained its open the
connection to the key bolt now what I
want to do is I want to create a key
inside the vault so I've called it
Steven haunt is key don't step over
Wi-Fi you can route so that's created a
key on the keyboard now so that's stored
off in a data center somewhere probably
the reason why it's running a bit slow
is I'm using one of the UK data centers
so going back over the Atlantic but we
get a key ID back so that's a UI right
to the key in the keyboard that's what
we're going to use to specify in our
encryption operations
so I've got a text ring here maybe had a
little lamb I want to encrypt that
message so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to convert it into a byte array
using the get bias method there and then
I'm also going to specify the key ID
I've done that I've now got a bite away
which is my data encrypted now I can
decrypt it if I convert both rows by two
ways back into strings and we can view
them so that's our encrypted text as a
base64 encoded string
and then see both the cryptid it's gone
back to mary had a little lamb' so
that's doing any encrypt and decrypt
operation using RSA on the HSM that's
kind of a task that's hello world in
Asia keyhole terms
but that is our hollow world to ever
know the key bolts working the type of
Wi-Fi is going to be kind to us today as
well which is good
different patterns and practices around
using the keyboard sees all things I've
sort of you know picked up and work
proof over the last or two or three
years of using keyboard so we're going
to talk about multiple environments
configuration of secrets local key
wrapping key versioning some little
trick to can do it password protection
and digital signatures those are the
things we're gonna work out so that's
what want to talk about multiple
environments so typically when we build
our systems we have production
environments UAT environment dev tests
and you know whatever environments you
need to get your systems and development
into production first thing you want to
make sure you don't do is just use one
shared key volt across all the view
environments you need to treat your
production system and your production
keys as completely secret so no
developers should ever have access to
them now you might do something like
this you know you might have a shared
key vault use for your test environment
and in a separate one for production
I've done that's at one company and that
worked quite well for us the one we use
for the test systems is using software
operations on the key volt and then the
one we had in production was the full
hardware at the higher cost version or
you could go a bit further you know if
you script with your environment you
just have a separate key volt per
environment both of those are fine but
just don't share the same bolts for
production or possible your test systems
that's a big security risk so
our secrets so as I said you can store
secrets on the key volt so they are a
maximum of 25k block to text and these
are stored in software but they're
encrypted using a master key on the HSM
so typical things you might want to
store the secrets of connection strings
API keys to foe party systems a redish
cache connection string I think I've
used before and just anything that you
don't really want to expose to anyone
yeah it's sort the sort of thing to you
sometimes panic and go through github
trying to delete those sorts of secrets
from config files now secrets are
versioned as well so if you have the
connection string and you call that
secret my connection string if you write
it again twice it'll create a second
version of it in the key vaults you
can't you do version control across
settings if you want to so
you
for this is incredibly straightforward
everything to do the Kibo musn't give
actually quite straightforward
if you download this source code it's
all written for you so just take it in
user you want to so again we're going to
instantiate the key vault I'm going to
create a secret called Steve Neurology
secret and again my secrets called mary
had a little lamb so I literally just
send that to the key vault
now that secret mary had a little lamb'
you sitting inside
hsm known as your data center into a
tree if you could just retrieve it by
name
let's pulled it back off the HSN then we
can see the text in our string there
then
easy to use it Natori is just a key
value store but it's unprotected
hardware so it's a great way in a very
simple way of protecting data
you
and this next one here is local key rap
and this is where we can actually start
to get the costs for Asia kevo
drastically reduced
so encrypting
HSN is generally expensive and I don't
necessarily mean cost I mean in terms of
network hops
I mean I'm accessing a keyboard was in
the UK and then you could see there was
a bit of latency in doing that so if
you've got to encrypt you know hundreds
or thousands of pieces of data in your
API calls or your websites that's going
to really affect performance so what we
want to do is want to use a technique
called local key wrapping so what this
means is all our encryption operations
will do locally using AES if it talks
about AES earlier it's a symmetric
encryption system but what we do is the
keys that we generate for AES we then go
and encrypt use an RSA key on the HSM
and once we've waited that AES key we
can just store in the database along
with our data in fact data gets
compromised and they get access to that
and is key it doesn't matter it's
encrypted it's just garbage unless I can
access a data center at Microsoft and be
printer just have a quick look at that
you
Sonia's projects here I've got some
extra classes I've got one called AES
encryption and that just does basic AES
encryption again you can just steal that
method for these methods so by es work
and give it a bite away today to know to
encrypt you give it a key so that's
maybe a 32 by random number which we're
going to generate then you give it
something called an initialization
vector and that's just a 16 byte random
number which you then need to store with
your data that just helps jumpstart AES
so we've got an encrypt operation and
they've got a decrypt operations that's
not is nothing as your key vault
specific there that's just standard AES
encryption in no also got em effort here
or classical random and this is what I'm
going to use to generate my local key so
it uses a class called RNG crypto
service provider really nice name II
know by Microsoft but what we do is we
pass in a length / 32 in our case of 32
bytes or 256 bit key instantiate the rng
crypto service provider we call get
bytes and then that returns us our photo
to by Atlanta number so that's how we're
going to generate our local key so let's
look at they in use right so instantiate
our key vault
I'm going to create a new key on the
keyboard
H of these own sample app creates and
deletes the keys at the end that tied us
up on to it so i so now what imma do is
I'm going to generate an encryption key
T with each of AES so I call my random
number generator and that gives me 32
bytes
array which is our locally encryption
key so now what I want to do is I want
to protect a encryption key with the key
Bowl so I call the encrypt method I'll
give it the key ID of the key on the key
volt and I pass in our local key
and now we have a completely encrypted
encryption key so you can convert that
to a base64 string and store it in your
database and go off and do something
else so then when you come back and you
want to do an encryption and decryption
operation before you can do that you
need to recover that encryption key you
can't use it as is it's encrypted by the
key volt
it's what we're going to do is we're
going to decrypt it so be passing the
encrypted key and the key ID of our
vault key
and that gets his back out key in there
Oh show me
yes we've got a photo T Blackie
recovered so now I'm going to generate
my initialization vector and add H is
just a 16 byte value you need to store
that with encrypted data
it doesn't it he kept secret so now I'm
going to do a local encryption operation
so I've got
a string here that want to encrypt make
a top-secret stuff
so I convert that to a byte array and
then I encrypt it so that's done locally
and so there's no key valve operations
oh I'm just encrypting locally in my
process then I can decrypt it
straightaway if I want to
so if I convert both those two strings
here you see the encrypted data there so
the string mega top secret stuff is
encrypted
and then when ID quit see you can see
I've recovered it so what we've done
there is quite powerful so we've managed
to use local key operations so we're not
constantly popping over to the HSN but
the key we're using that local key
operation we're protecting of the HSM so
if you've got a really big high scale
system you're doing lots of encrypts and
decrypts operations you sort of been
charged you know three cents per ten
thousand operations all we've done is a
couple of operations that we've created
a key now we've encrypted and we've
decrypted our master key so free
operations but then you might have ten
thousand local operations you know local
encryption operations but you're not
being charged for that activity in there
locally that's a good way of bringing
your costs down so they've actually
nothing
okay
it's an example where I've used this
with the last class on my used it I was
working for a company that does
insurance claims management so we was
building the software as a service
solution so it was our solution but then
we could onboard
insurance companies onto that system so
uses in a few ways so
every time being bought a new company
William Tennent no they get completely
rebranded version of the system to their
branding that's a multi-tenant system
now what we did to be made sure that
each of the insurance companies that
came on had their own sets of master
keys those master keys where RSA keys
are stored on the evolve and then what
we do is the data that we're dealing
with those insurance companies we
encrypt and decrypt it locally in our
system so we were encrypting things like
the claimants information so names
address phone numbers email addresses of
the person making the claim and in some
of the claimed the details so the
vehicle details was also encrypted so if
anyone ever came in and stolen any of
our data from cosmos DB or super server
all that data is encrypted but a good
thing is because each insurer had its
own set of master keys effectively what
you're getting is partitioning vial
encryption so everyone stay to restore
together in one big database but the
data was effectively partitioned because
it was using different keys polling sure
to encrypt their data so basically what
that looked like a very high level so we
had you know go our system on the left
there at the top we ran a whole bunch of
app services and web services and all
that stuff but its sequel server
databases and cost more state spaces and
then each insurer gets her own key in
the key bonds so locally in our database
was storing something up at the bottom
so you've got a tenant ID that's the
idea for an insurance company
but the key ID which is that you I
arrived at we told them the greater the
key and then we have a bunch of
encrypted AES session keys which are the
local keys of use for insurance company
so advantages own so this means doing
encryption smoke encryptions a lot
faster because you're not constantly
hopping over to the key vault
you're just using it to crate and
recover a key so as you go into an a Web
API method it would request the key
flight insurance company peak repair
local carrier and we could do a whole
bunch of encryption and decryption
operations in one going it also makes it
easy to rotate rotate keys as well so a
lot of companies yeah you don't have a
security officer and one of the rules
they might put in place is that you have
to change master encryption keys every
thirty days for example now if you're
not doing local key wrapping and you're
encrypting all of your data in your
database using just that master key and
hom when you change that key in keyboard
you think got to go and re encrypt all
of your data so that's incredibly
inefficient and not very practical we're
at the local key wrapping variance when
you change the key in the key volt all
you have to do is decrypt a namely
encrypt that local key you don't need to
touch any of your other data because the
AES key you're using to encrypt that
data is the same you're just protects me
from different key in keyboards so again
that makes it very easy for you to
gather a routine and change your keys
you can even automate deeply to say
every X amount of days change the key on
the key volt and industry equipment
local P
so we get some definite benefits there
okay so next one is key versioning so
changing keys over time is important is
kind of like the digital equivalent of
changing your locks when you've been
broken into and although you wouldn't
necessarily just wait until you've had a
data breach to change your keys as we
said you might do it for you to me
there's a couple of ways or couple of
techniques we can use around here so
this is what we just looked at so you
know you've got a key in the key volt
which might be version 1 and use that to
encrypt your AES key
you might remove that key and create a
new one which is Q 1.1 which means you
just need to re-encrypt that one local
key the rest of your data doesn't need
to be touched another thing you can do
so including friends with keys I'll give
you an example of where I've used this
in a minute so what this means is you
might have key version 1 and encrypt a
whole bunch of data for that key then
you create a new key which is Q 1.1
instead of touching any of that existing
data you just start using that key going
forward so you have some data encrypted
with key version 1 and then the rest of
the data and clicked the key version 2
and as you increase or you know you
create key version 1.3
carry on encrypting from that point an
example of where I've used this is a
retail finance company's working at was
going through PCI compliance and we
decided to build our own PCI card token
vault this is a effectively a secure
database on a separate network but we
store everyone's card details credit
card numbers so the policy we had on
that and was working with a PCI auditor
to help build this is that we had a
policy where say every 250 cards would
get stored in the key vault there in
their card holders we were changed to
key every 256 pub it might be 200 or so
cards that comes in
so that's an example where you can use
influence appears so past my protector
where you can do some other little
tricks he's in the key vault when it
comes to storing passwords in the system
we'll know passwords aren't great the
technologists we hate them because
they're very insecure but they're here
to stay and they're not really going to
change because it's easy for our end
users so let's go through a little
potted history of how to do it passwords
so everyone can agree that plaintext
passwords about a four she just did a
lot of sites out that'd do it anyone
seen the plaintext offenders website
they're companies who use plaintext
passwords get outed to the rest of the
internet it's worth googling it's quite
funny but plaintext passwords we can all
agree that's bad so the next off next
way what making people do is use hash
passwords by someone touching their
password my password and you create a
hash of it try to eat six hash for an
md5 hash and you store it in the
database does anyone work on systems it
does it that way
a few so that that's been one of the
common ways of doing it unfortunately
that's a problem with that and it's very
easy to brute force those passwords to
recover them or to do what's called a
dictionary or very very table attack so
when you use tools our cash camp which
is a freely downloadable bit of open
source software that uses your hardware
GPU to try and brute force passwords
using massive multi-gigabyte diction
poems so if you're just doing hashing
the passwords chart is actually very
easy to recover that password I'm a
teacher workshop on this now last time I
did it I hadn't sold 15 people in a room
and there's all running hash cat at the
same time trying to break low the
passwords and it can to kind of warm the
room up quite a bit it was all running
it but everyone managed to recover all
the passwords
so hash in it's better than plaintext
passwords but it's not perfect a good
example of a site here called crack
station net this is always good to
showing demo switch if you're trying to
prove and security principles to people
in your office so you go to that website
you put in your hash password at the top
type in a quick capture hit crack
passwords you know it's worked out there
so sha-256 hash and password secret 69
many things I go and download the
password table that they're using as
well like website
so hash passwords better if it's not all
great so a better solution end users do
salted hash passwords and what it is is
it's kind of the same as what we just
looked at with hash passwords but you
add what's called a salt on the end of
the password so typically when I've done
this I've just generated a fair - by
random number and then just appended it
and see enter the password and then
hashed it then you store the hash
password and that salting database and
that makes it much harder for towards
our hash cat to be able to crack
passwords but as GPUs get more powerful
you know what they go what they can be
like in the next five to ten years you
know the password that salted in hash
now that might be secure might be
compromised in a few years time because
of the advent of GPU processing power
which is commonly used to crack these
passwords
you want to try and beat Moore's law you
don't want the advent of faster machines
making it easier to crack passwords the
neck popular one issue sign called a
password-based key derivation function
or bcrypt
does anyone use anything on that moment
okay so the mechanism built into dotnet
is called a password-based key
derivation function there's another one
called beat crypt which isn't supported
in neck you can get open-source
implementations of it and the way this
works is you have a password and you
have a salt just have all that talked
about before then you pass in a number
of iterations and what this does is it
repeatedly hashes the password and then
you get a final action at the end so
what this is doing is its
algorithmically slowing down the
password hashing process so if you
imagine it's alright hash cap using the
fast set of GPUs it might be able to
attempt you know two billion possible
combinations a second if your algorithm
pretty slow that process down then it
might only be able to check take say ten
a second and five a second and go on how
many iterations you pass them you're
making it much harder for people to
crack those passwords and stir this in
but it's incredibly simple it's just
that you've got a class here called RFC
2 8 9 8 / X ok another bit of fantastic
naming but you just part in a byte array
of your password by it array of your
salt and a number of iterations then you
say get by it's 20 reason you say 20s
because it's using sha-1 under the cover
it's not trying to 56 and that's a 20 by
the hash code
look at you know examples of numbers of
iterations where I tested this at one
point so you know 100 iterations might
take two milliseconds thousand
iterations might take 16 all the way up
to five hundred thousand iterations
which might take seven seconds as you
can see the higher the number you get
linear growth in the amount of time now
if you're building that into your system
you need to work out what's an
acceptable that at the time for
someone's weight so maybe we've ever
been on any websites where you type the
password in which feels like you're
waiting about two or three seconds for
it to login that's quite because it's
doing something like this or bcrypt
behind the scenes you need to work out
what's in sensible amount of delay for
your users so we good yeah that's a good
way of protecting passwords but what we
can do is go one little step further and
add just a little bit extra for part of
our basic a derivation function using
keyboards just gives a bit of extra
security this is what we just looked at
but what we can do now is we can say
that once we've hashed that password you
can then generate a hash message
authentication code of that hash the
password remember what I said earlier H
Mac is just like a normal hat you have
to pass in a key and it's a 32 by random
number I believe AES now you can then go
and protect that key using keyboards
using low key wrapping that we just
looked at so actually what we're doing
to it saying here we've got this hash
password but we're doing is extra
hashing operation using a key which you
have to recover with the key bolt and
then we store in the results of that
fashion our base base so doing
is very straightforward and this is how
you do it in map there's a class called
HVAC sha-256 passing a byte array of
your key and you just call compute hash
passing in byte array of what you want
actually it just returns the result what
does this mean so it means if your
password tables are stolen and then
you've got people using tools our hash
cat to try and recover your passwords
even though you slowed them down using a
part of our basic ear evasion function
before they can even attempt to attack
that hash they've got to get through the
hash mark that you've done first but the
only way they can do that is if they
know the key that you pass into the hate
remark about keys protect CDs and
Yvonne's so just gives you that little
extra sort of wrapper of protection
around your passwords this makes doing
you know dictionary rainbow table
attacks virtually impossible so going to
recover that key they've got to access
to key vault no market off data center
now Microsoft are very good at build
insecure data centers so one could
practice for this is if you are doing
this you might want to have different
hash mark keys for different roles in
your businesses you know we say we use
the key role to protect the hashmap key
and that key to do a hash mark or you
might have different keys for different
roles like admin users internal
employees and customers you might decide
you only want to give this extra level
of protection to admin accounts
partly so you want to do so you only
take that performance hit for admin
passwords that's up to you that's kind
looking at the driver
okay so in this class when they say
projects I've got a sample code for
building a hashmap or we've slipped out
on the screen
I've got the sample code for doing a
part of our base key derivation function
so let's use those together again you
can just download this and play with it
and you know get a good feel of it
yourself so I'm going to create a new
key on the keyboard this is a master key
that I've created I'm now going to
generate a local key this is what we did
before let me do the local key wrap in
and I'm going to encrypt that key so
that's exactly the same as what we did
in the last demo so I'm going to store
that key in our database it's encrypted
so now let's come back so we want to
hash a password so first of all I'm
going to decrypt that key and then we're
going to have a string here of a really
secure password know what no one will
ever guess that because I've put numbers
instead of letters I generate my salt so
just like the voice of a to you by
clanging number so now wonder it is I'm
going to hash the password so I'm using
that part of a base key derivation
function converting my password into the
byte array and providing the salt in
this case I'm using 20,000 iterations
so now I have a hashed password as a
buyer to Wayne and that's where a lot of
people normally stop you convert that to
a base64 encoded string and you're still
in the database and that's your hashed
password so now what we're gonna do is
we're going to protect the password
using the key Bowl
well using the kids protected by the
keyboard so wonders I'm gonna create a
hash Mac 256 and a part in the hash
passwords this is the password has
already gone through key derivation
function I'm going to pass in now the
cryptic cake we've already recovered the
key is in the Kibo
I just put your display those in the
console
so you detect a bit small on that one to
apologize but if you look at the top
password
this has hash password that's the one
that we've done with the password-based
key derivation function see it's quite
short easy sha-1 for that hashing
process but now I've gone and done a
hash message authentication code of it
using our key that we will cover fire
the key vault move rehashed it now it's
now giving us a much bigger hash we then
going to store that in our database only
user logs any we want to check the
password first of all we decrypt the
local key calculate the hash mark and
then we can also then go and calculate
the part of the base key derivation
function
time
you
okay so the last patterns we look at
then is doing digital signatures and
digital signing with the key bolt as we
said before so we've got four pillars
cryptography confidentiality integrity
authentication and non-repudiation so
we've kind of covered the first free and
non-repudiation is about placing digital
signatures so a digital signature is a
mathematical technique used to validate
your fantasy and integrity of a message
software or digital document 1001 use
services at DocuSign and sign contracts
effectively what that's doing is
generating digital signatures about
document and there's three things you
need to do that so you need to do key
generation we've already got that we've
seen that already with the key volt you
need to signing algorithm and you need a
signature verify algorithm the way this
typically works is you first of all hash
some data so you might have a massive
PDF of a document buying a house for
example and create a hash of that
document and then you use either a
sha-256 hash or a hash mag to hash that
document and then you create a digital
signature of that hash and the reason
for that is because the digital
signature under the covers is using RSA
and there's a limit on RSA and how much
you can encrypt in one go
you can't encrypt more than the size of
the key to run the limitations of RSA
that's why we create the hash first and
we'd sign the hash of the data now if we
take a look at this typically with RSA
when you encrypt data you can quit using
the recipients public key then e decrypt
using their private key digital
signature itself way around - in this
case Bob takes his private key only he
knows it he creates a digital signature
of the data and then sends it over the
internet or the big spider's web
development
Alice receives official signature then
she uses Bob's public key to validate or
verify the signature if it comes back as
true she knows that message definitely
came from Bob as only he has accessed
that private key
if
fire comes back as false then she
doesn't trust it because it can't have
been involved it's in that message there
in nets when we do this manually without
the key volt there's two classes to be
used RSA pkcs1 signature formatter and
RSA pkcs1 signature v4 matter in game
brilliantly named classes is why a lot
of people miss them in the framework but
we don't need to use those becomes the
key volt so we've got no need to use
those signature formats of classes let's
go and have a look at that
you
so Craig McKee volts creating your key
so I've got a document here or a piece
of information I'm going to create a
signature for it says this is a very
important document could be a PDF
document could be a file the only thing
so first of all I'm going to create a
hash without basis that's using just a
standard sha-256 hash in notes that
gives me the the hash in here recorded
document digests it just basically a
hash of that document now I'm gonna use
the key vault
I'm gonna pass it on to call the Sion
operation I'm going to give it my key ID
so it knows what key to use and it's
going to use the public key so the
private key that's stored in the key
ball and I could get the hash of that
document
so I've now got a bite away containing
my signature and you can you know store
that send it off to someone now I want
to verify their signatures valid so
again I pass in the PID document digest
and the signature into the verify method
in this case it's going to come back
it's going to say true
that's our happy path so it's valid and
you'll be trust it let's run it again
you
document I create the hash Mike rate the
signature just as you did before I'm a
dodgy hacker I'm gonna come in and I'm
gonna mess around with the original
document so I'm just gonna go to that
byte array just change the first byte
so now what happens is when I pass in
the document digest I've just messed
around with and the signature in to
verify
it's in a compact and safe false because
that digital signature doesn't match the
document that we passed in that verify
operation is done on a jerky bolt and
the hardware
you
okay so in summary when they we talked
about the fact that data breaches are
getting worse there that happen all the
time and but only four percent of those
data breaches in a class are secure so
no reducing that top number is going to
be very difficult what we want to do is
you want to increase that bottom numbers
if it ever does happen to your company
you want to be in that four percent or
that you only get the four percent
higher but you want to be glasses as
secure data breach
so the or date is effectively worthless
to anyone who steals it
so breaches are inevitable you're never
going to get round it so it's not a case
of if faced with when there's a good
mindset change to take we've taken a
look at as your key vault
so we talked about the fact that you
know traditionally hardware security
modules have been very expensive to
prohibitive for many small companies but
Microsoft has very kindly produced a
wrapper around a set of very expensive
hardware that we can use and using the
techniques we've looked at we can get
that cost down to virtually nothing
they've built there's around the fan
essential hardware and I'm not quite
sure how much this device costs when I
went to the websites I have a lock it so
you know getting contact details which
generally means expensive using the key
vaults very simple so it sets up the key
vault is very simple and the
instructions on Microsoft website
actually very good it gives you a lot of
good exploration about how to set it up
that we talked about one of four
different patterns and sort of the
practices that you can do around use and
a key votes we looked at how with
environments you want to make sure
you've got two separate Hardware key
volt for your production environments
never share that key load within a
system we looked at how you can use the
key bolt to store secrets and things
like connection strings application keys
one sort of stuff it's a good thing to
do store at my Tivo we looked at local
key wrapping so you can get some
performance improvement so you're not
hopping across the key volt at the times
when the crypt everything you can just
use local AES keys which are protected
by the key volt but you can then do very
fast encryption operations locally we
looked at how you can use key version if
you want to and you don't have to use
versioning if you don't want to mean my
job was didn't use versioning but if you
do need to use it it's natively
supported as part of the API you can
request specific versions of keys if
needed we looked at how you can use the
key volt so I just a little bit of extra
protection to securing passwords and
then we finally looked at how you can
use two key valve with the additional
signature they can make that sort of
process very easy using the vault all of
the source code that we looked at is
available there so you can just take it
and do all of it it's released under MIT
it's been natively built for dotnet core
just because doesn't cause the new your
hot stuff and I wanted to use it on my
Mac and not have to run up my windows VM
if you are using don't know framework
the codes fine each need to put into a
normal framework project so if this
ain't you interested in any once or more
references after this talk to finish
because your brains would have melted
out for the next two days so if you want
to go back and pick any of this stuff up
I've got two courses at my help the
play-by-play which talked about a Shiki
volt and how to get it set up and how to
use it and then I've got my practical
cryptography net of course which goes
into a sort of much more deeper dive
about a lot of crypto primitives in
dotnet and how to use them all together
to finding really scratch the surface of
what can do some of those primitives
as plug our latest course it's called
blockchain principles and practices if
any of you are curious as to help block
change work all about this course takes
you through the theory and it also
gradually builds up a blockchain
implementation in C sharp and dotnet
it's kind of like a computer science
course it teaches you the fundamental
principles of how it works is what I
found is a lot of companies you sit in
the boardroom and the directors like we
need a blockchain they have not a cheat
no idea what one is it's just a tool and
most of the time it's not suitable so
this course actually helps developers
understand what they are what they can
be used for and you actually go through
the process of building one by hand and
also write a load of books and publish
on Amazon latest one is on social
engineering attack on prevention teaches
you how to think like a criminal so you
can better protect yourself from a lot
of their tricks and that's it thank you
very much I'm going to be around for the
next two days and at the party as well
so feel free to come over and say hi and
my twitter address is down there it's
good to have discussions in public on
Twitter doors are nice thank you